des petits parasol pour ce qui rend au
stack et brassards verts rouges toujours
les écharpes des casquettes l'ajout ball
[Musique]
tu venu acheter le chapeau pour le match
fois mario tischer et si le prix a bondi
manger de tout ça
j'ai acheté maillot et puis les gadgets
les chapeaux j'ai acheté le drapeau et
j'ai acheté une casquette c'est les
casquettes ou les enfants comme le
cameroun a analysé la coupe contre le
mans que les caméras se sentent
concernés et il faut que les enfants
s'habituent senti que le maillet à
l'accrocheuse
w tu déjà ce jour là vous ne me croirez
pas si vous dit j'ai fait mais c'est à
21h il ya eu du mal à fermer la palud
pour à un moment donné que je repousse
le les clients pour pouvoir fermer
[Musique]
et ça il se disait que le jeune et
demande
bien les égyptiens qui avaient besoin de
leur drapeau il ya beaucoup bukina faso
ceux qui sont juste en face de l'hôtel
qui a en face de nous la qui voulait
aussi le drapeau et les maillots ya eu
des gabonais qui m'ont passé la commande
pratiquement de six cartons de maillots
et des gadgets